[Music]
in sell your face news how much yes
submitted by attack of the Roombas what
are you doing don't pay attention okay a
tech firm is looking to pay someone to
lend their likeness to a new line of
robot assistants oh never mind
well maybe I think a lot I'll do it for
like five million your likeness for five
million yeah I know I don't want to do
it but then if the price is right I'm
down I'll do it for a new Ford Raptor ah
you [ __ ] competitive Chinese I'm not
putting your face on a robot yeah does
the robot just nag people all day we're
gonna have sex with the robot I'm down
he mouthed be five million dollars
richer and I'm not gonna be in their
house okay they're doing that right now
my money you've been doing it yeah so
this tech firm is looking for the right
person to lend their likeness for a new
line of robot assistants that they would
be assisting the elderly
that's scary bro what's the right person
you just have to have a really
nice-looking face or like yeah maybe
like super neutral like symmetrical like
yeah they're saying a kind and friendly
face I'm out welcoming this RBF is
[ __ ] out and you know old people are
the most racist so they are that's true
a white person well it depends on what
kind of old person it is mm-hmm
just truth I'm old people don't like
white people I think it's gotta be
Indian guy mm I never seen a threatening
Indian got my entire life they all look
very friendly but ethnically ambiguous
yeah I would I think like friendly
equals female I don't think friendly and
think of a guy I think a female I do
[ __ ] you know they're [ __ ] you
think I'm a [ __ ] did you just call
yourself for RBF yeah you know what that
stands for yeah
what is it sound for resting [ __ ]
yeah but I'm not a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's funny so they are willing to pay
the chosen candidate about 130,000 I'm
out I'm out I'll do it I could buy two
for draft for your likeness in
perpetuity Bret you're in perpetuity yep
there we go
define dates do it do it
dude that's enough money I think you're
reciting Eminem work for less than that
oh [ __ ]
you look crazy as [ __ ] like you just
[ __ ] got picked up from the side of
the road right now why like he just went
time-traveling I don't want to wear my
hat right now because it started to hurt
my head okay I'll do my hair for the
likeness obviously they're not gonna
take me like this do you thought this in
to be like in this robot I don't know no
I don't think so they just want your
like measure our friend Julie's on is
like she's on that Apple icon like at
the bottom oh yeah this is crazy
yeah but small you can't tell who she is
you can oh the photo booth that don't
that one oh yeah that one what that's
her what is it mine the last eight years
did you get paid it's about like three
years Wow holy wait longer than that I
think she get paid a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars yeah how do you get
that gig I don't know that I don't know
how much you got paid she does
commercial work stuff you know what I
think has the friendliest face in the
world maybe Steve Carell he kind of got
rapey face sometimes he was my robot my
friend II wrote friendly robot as an old
person I don't know what about Will
Smith he's kind of scary too sometimes
they actually mention Will Smith I was
thinking Will Ferrell who Ellen Ellen
would be a good robot
she looks like she could be me yeah like
if I didn't know her now sitting across
I'd be like oh man like is this her
entertainment face and then like I just
can't imagine her going like who Ray
Romano yeah he's pretty good
it's pretty nice he's their own how
about Adele she looks like a
kindergarten teacher she's nice
someone with dimples somebody that
somebody fat ginger defer a lot Lawrence
oh did you guys ever see smart house it
was a Disney Channel movie um Peg Bundy
yeah Peg Bundy me like the actress me
anyway she's not perfect yeah have you
seen her sons of anarchy
yeah between her and smart house I don't
know she's pretty bird Gemma and Peggy
you know cuz I would let your mom in
that one she's supposed to be like the
way didn't he what's her name she used
to date Charlie Denise Richards Denise
Richards yeah how I can't think of any
names
yeah thinking of sex robots I think you
are being like smiley like who I don't
want a [ __ ] person I don't want to
[ __ ] the person that's helping me when I
have a broken leg I'm gonna be my robot
heart and if she you're paying her I
think she's gonna make sure you survive
oh well she said Natalie Portman oh yeah
yeah I was gonna I was thinking about
her too yeah these are all female Paula
Deen's she's like nice-looking she's the
most racist though Bush if you look at
her because we know her history right
but she looks like smells like pies
that's what I'm saying like cinnamon
women are nurturing TIFF
but what about Santa Claus Robin
Williams in Bicentennial man a black
Santa he's like the dad that visits you
once a year on your birthday but it's
Jesus's birthday and he gives you
presents but he was like you don't see
him the rest of the year actually you
don't even see him there's something
about a fat guy who's down a had kids
random kids sit on his lap uh no more no
girl I'd want to be coddled by him the
hard pass will you take TECA to go see
Santa
abso-fucking-lutely
he's going to be the weird kid I'm still
gonna be like watching his hands the
whole time but I'm not gonna have him be
the weird [ __ ] homeschooled kid sorry
for you were homeschooled you're like
weird what about a sumo wrestler
they're pretty cuddly no way they're
intimidating but you're I mean these
robots are gonna be helping the elderly
like I forgot the elderly part why are
we talking about how this is scary as
[ __ ]
because it's not robots can be nice Geo
but they're gonna get really smart
really fast well you know what I think
of when I read this story Bicentennial
man the movie with Robin Williams Robin
Williams it was saying earlier I'm like
dude cute like this that movie is
exactly what this reminds me of cuz he
was like a palace
robot the house daddy oh they serve it
but that sounded bad Robin Williams just
yeah he'd be good let's ask him I'll
give good likeness I don't know how to
break it what guys never mind dude let's
just say Robin Williams and Santa Claus
are kicking it together oh that's nice
so they come Christmases yeah they do
how does how does a robot work for the
elderly like is it actually like I don't
know so right now this company they are
being like anonymous and stuff they're
just kind of like they don't want oh
that's weird that's the weird part that
is really weird
they are the anonymous it's new stuff
new company don't want to share all
their secrets but why even share that
they need that posting anonymous robot
company that's all the postings are
that's all the postings are like in the
beginning when Amazon first start but
before we get that don't forget to
subscribe
um they would have posting like hey we
need people for a new startup it's gonna
grow really fast highly disciplined
[ __ ] I'm not gonna tell you
anything and that's how all the posters
are for these startups but they weren't
asking you for your face but this one is
yeah so be like due to the project's
secretive nature that's why they hired
this robotics recruiter company called
geo mix and they're the ones that are
trying to
filtered through this process and like
try to try to get there your person so
is it a lot of focus groups of like does
this face scare you does this face look
friendly and then like them trying to
match like the perfect face to the
person so they look at their headshots
and trying to match it
maybe I wonder if it's still sexual
harassment if you asked a robot for a
[ __ ] no I guess not
okay just just good to know so a lot of
people or not a lot but like other
people they were wondering why can't
this company to save money and use an
online random face generator who gives a
[ __ ] about the face I could have an
empty face I need somebody to help me
that scare you at night imagine like
it's just that [ __ ] empty abyss well
why does it have to be a humanoid like
what can it be well like you know like
Betamax or some shade or like a big
furry dog I'm so damn alright big cuddly
ass Betamax or like a dinosaur or like
man people are so boring like why do you
want other people like dinosaur helping
you yeah or like the iRobot robots like
these with the Will Smith movie because
they mentioned in this article how it's
like you have virtual friends or
whatever like a robotic being but it
doesn't look like a human you're right
like I think that is less scary than it
actually looking like a person like make
it like something from their time you
know like like Marilyn Monroe [ __ ] or
John F Kennedy your social expenses
forget the like mister I didn't even
know people Alda likeness I don't know
maybe I think that'll be pretty cool or
remember um [ __ ] Harry Anderson
sasquatch or like Chewbacca or something
I like mouth the anteater yeah that'd be
cool yeah look you look like that
anteater yeah little helpers that are
like big bears Smurfs yeah that'll be
pretty cool a [ __ ] paw patrol I don't
like how it has to be human relate with
the tic TOCs or watch
I don't like that it has to be human I
think that's stupid would you guys be
down a higher one of these robots yeah
what do you have the robot dude yeah
what do they do their jobs no it's a
humanoid right grapes here my bed put on
my clothes like literally I'm not moving
ever again it can pick you up ass that's
why you got a lift though so you stay
strong and keep your bones healthy if
they never come but then what's the
point so you don't get a robot to do it
well you can have the robot in case you
fall that's why I think a robot would be
good for fall so you don't have to hit
your life alert button or your life
alert button is connected to your robot
you say yo robot I fell zero I can skip
that whole step and then just become the
body of the robot yeah just implant your
brain with your spinal cord all I wanted
my body still but just like as this like
Iron Man yes yeah you want your body as
a suit yeah it already is a suit for
your season it's like iron never love
you outside not on the inside not on the
outside not Wolverine mmm
[Music]
you